hey yo what's poppin lo gang it's me
your boy and I'm in Tokyo and it is lit
I'm a super jet lag we arrived at 7 in
the morning and yeah it's it's rough man
jet lag is rough me
this view is seriously the coolest we're
staying in Shibuya for 5 days and then
we're gonna travel around Japan hey hey
hey look what I found
boy I even got this tiny bottle from
7-eleven so cute I love Japan so now
we're going to the shunryo store PJ &
Sophie is here hello and it's gonna be
late
[Music]
but it'd be basically senator you have
flew us here so we're gonna hang out
with them for five days and let's see
what they got inside so cute oh my god
me they literally have Hello Kitty
anything I need to step up my March game
man do we have it 35,000 yen to spend
they gave us just to buy whatever why
not get a Hello Kitty cane oh that's
awesome
I'm too tall there you go
fantastic I didn't realize I made such
an insane face when I did I look at that
boy
[Music]
oh my god they have Tamagotchis we go to
Tom ah-ha done she'll tangi Tanjore
enjoy
oh he's born so we're using like this
translator at big satisfied large more
desert also yeah I don't know if
I'm ready for this responsibility we got
a crazy crossing happening here
bringin sad this is not the big big one
but it's pretty big it's four degrees
out it's really cold but I feel pretty
awake
[Music]
I don't know how we ended up here but
pretty chill it's a little bench here
you can just sit
our dog sitter wins those pictures
there's Edgar not wanting to leave the
beach we are at the restaurant from the
famous scene in Kill Bill you know where
oh my is is slicing everyone this is so
cool
all right we just came back it was a
really amazing dinner I ate so much tuna
and then we just came back to the room
in this view now I remember why I missed
Japan everyone was kind of tired but it
was perfect anyway see you tomorrow
4head whats up squad fam it's your boy
today we're going to a theme park which
is called puroland what is he doing so
even at the station they have like the
Sun Ryu figurines I like the little
butthole what is happening here Dan
I've died didn't come to cuteness heaven
there it is
oMG what's wrong with you pj don't don't
keep keep your stupid snow in your
pocket
look la
[Music]
I had to check it parole and here we
come
oh my God look at that Wow what we're
going through the theater to check out a
good otama show I don't know what's
happening oh my god oh my god oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm either in heaven or house now that's
some sexy legs boy
what what do you got going there this
thing yeah what is a
[Music]
[Applause]
getting over here
Shannon are you ready
[Music]
[Applause]
already got the cinnamon cinnamon that
was amazing
I don't know what I just watched but it
was great
it's my dress now curry
is my dress and now you've glitched it
PJ that's Hello Kitty's bad pain today
that's Hello Kitty's bad stopping stuff
Hello Kitty is waiting for us in that
door it's gonna happen it's finally this
whole trip is this is a living way I
[Music]
think she was really into me we're about
to meet good at time I himself this is
very lips that is so creepy he's coming
he's coming
PJ it's coming we're gonna meet
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh good its hammer
good its hammer this is it don't do it
don't do it yeah here we go
we're leaving goodbye Pure Land
good morning it's another day another
left to live it I ran out yesterday to
buy this jacket I love it so much my
favorite brands waka Maria it's
reversible as well so funny
we're gonna do some more shopping today
I'm really excited we have some more
time we are at Tokyo Station look how
pretty it is with all the lights I'm
gonna try my luck at the Gacha pod I
really want the pop team epoch one look
at those yeah we're hard tjuku and we're
gonna apparently check out some
hedgehogs at the Hedgehog cafe I'm a the
best Hedgehog repression oh my god who
are those guys over there
can I dab
Hey oh thank you good luck on the race
they made it to the blog there it is
it's happening don't eat them so this is
our Hedgehog so he's very cute his leg
is all up in the air talking on the
phone this is like a special one I like
holds on we're going in here now oh my
God look at this food I want that one
alright just kidding I'm getting this
one a vegetarian can you shut oh my god
we got
oh no pump I'm sorry no pom-pom please
pom-pom tastes good though oh my god we
get it we get a mug I'm gonna eat you
mmm it's really good actually
do need me yeah yeah oh damn
little stump syrup master Oh I want to
learn oh my God why would you do that
something's about to happen if you don't
know what that was we met with 107 years
character who is like a work B but when
she gets angry she gets like into heavy
metal and like really aggressive it's
fun meeting all these like characters is
really weird it's really awkward and
strange was really funny
Oh what are you doing PJ you're not a
son real boy he's such a doofus this is
my favorite
kissing man do you want a photo spot
with me what about how do we like we're
like having a private tour on the expo
whenever one lands give us the money and
who doesn't want a Hello Kitty laundry
machine thank you
this one is so cute alright we've been
out for like 11 hours we're going to the
ninja cafe right now restaurant we are
entering the ninja training
oh and second cave we need to up the
bridge is that what's happening I'm
really scared
I think she's lying to us there's no one
coming it's currently nothing happening
I'm waiting for the enemy oh the enemy's
not gonna get us now we're almost there
poor me hot stone real hard how hot is
it a million degrees why that's really
hot I did it that was me we're gonna
meet with the creator of good otama and
it's gonna teach us how to make how to
draw but we're not allowed to film her
and she's a because she's a secret
identity just like I am whenever anyone
asks Who I am
it's this it's this a little on let's go
this view is insane this is the room we
weren't yesterday now we're gonna get
taught how to draw yeah you got this
ball Michelle what do I do now hey you
find it difficult I think we did it come
on thanks we can do this thanks we all
wish it didn't turn out
so we got original drawing of gudetama
and i get to go up very cool
this puts ours to shame that was super
fun everyone was so nervous before but
we all had a good time I was scared I
was gonna offend a head I think you did
actually PA yours was pretty yeah
she was we're going here to do like this
VR game
[Music]
[Applause]
that was amazing that was way cooler
than I thought it would be I've done VR
before but I was like so much better
Wow PJ you look great and all its glory
beautiful so beautiful oh my god
[Music]
finally at the famous Shibuya crossing
everyone is crossing people just walking
across spelling
pretty how is it pretty big it's pretty
big it's gonna be the last day I get to
see this view in a long time boy
we're leaving Tokyo today and we're
going to Osaka where we have a lot of
cool stuff planned as well the trip is
not over yet
I bought this Gundam I'm so excited for
it you can't really buy like good
condoms in UK all right it's still cool
as but it's not a model you just
put the pieces together I was really
hoping to build it I might buy another
one then because I'm an idiot he is cool
but I wanted to build him god damn a
welcome we're in Osaka Osaka we've been
traveling all day this room has no
windows in it so it seems like it could
be any time any time I don't know what
time is it a bit different view then
from what we had in Tokyo we spend the
last three hours trying to track down
our tickets it didn't work but we're
here at the venue are you guys excited
excited we got this again all right
there we go
[Music]
okay so I mean Osaka getting tattoo just
like me tattoo from really cool artists
it's not just sleepy I like the Falk
lore of it and then when sleepy passed
away I was like oh yeah
I definitely want to get something so
I'm really glad I'm finally getting a
tattoo I'm really excited
there it is he's playing done looks
really good look at that so cool I love
it that's a tortoise didn't speak a lot
of English neither do i apparently but
he told us that it's illegal to get
tattoos in Japan which I didn't that's
true it's not illegal to get it is
illegal to make tattoos unless you have
a medical license I knew it was illegal
in South Korea I didn't know it was in
in Japan but it's interesting I guess
that's why we were in like this outside
of Tokyo not in a studio Oh
okay we're at aquarium now it's raining
like crazy my feet are wet
life is tough good luck seeing anything
oh my god what is he chewing on look at
that fish right there thanks I'll just
whack he's loving it look at that guy
look at this guy doesn't look like it
being so big oh my god it's the end oh
my god they got isopods thanks Epona how
is happening look at all the ice upon
info go away sound cool
look at these losers you got any good
fish down there PJ now with the video
won't have ants on it oh my god it's the
eel from Super Mario just sit back shut
PJ there's so many people it's miss Ari
who you I am very poorly friend like you
know what
that is myself
[Music]
there
my god it's so amazing this is so big
oh this is the best fish this fish
should not exist does it even know
what's up and down hey man you look
pretty good now you look pretty good
no you look good no I Love You Man now I
love you man I love you mommy
you know I love you even more man you
are the most beautiful thing I have ever
seen in my life now you are the most
beautiful thing I have ever seen in my
life
ah thanks main fresh just use all of us
holy SH H P didn't know you were a crowd
you've already made that joke Wow Brad
is not editing this hey everybody its PJ
I do arts and crafts videos
what are you doing there Marcia you made
a new friend follow me it's the best
fish of them all me
looks like PJ finally made a friend made
a jerk I need the Hat give it to me
yes yeah I never thought this moment
would happen you're coming home with me
we're gonna have the best time
his name is jump on and we love each
other
sorry I marched yeah well look at the
ferris wheel that's so cool we're back
at the hotel I just cleaned the tattoo
thanks again to husky I think Huck C for
doing it very happy with it the shirt I
bought I had such a rush to buy it I
didn't look properly it's clearly fake I
don't even like supreme that much but I
really like the Akira collection it goes
in the trash so annoying oh well not
everything we're excited well now we're
gonna go out to eat probably won't vlog
anything more well actually it's rainy
and it's very pretty but that's not why
you watch my vlogs is it what's up
what's up what's up what's up today
we're going to almost like a castle and
then we're gonna go to Hakone what am I
gonna do get a squad no it's just me
thank you
it's interesting contrast of like old
and then new they have ducks do you see
that hey I found him I found him there
is photo up there we go
1 million stairs we made it to the top
look at that view boy what a panoramic
view it's very cold don't drop the
camera Felix don't drop it
did you make a new friend PJ
so yeah look at you
it's called I don't like it here guys
can we go home please
hey guys it's me we are in Hakone right
now which is a bit outside of Tokyo it's
famous for its hot springs
we're out late so you can't see the
views but it's snow outside it's really
beautiful I'm loving this we've been
travelling for a long time I'm tired and
we are here we are here now they have
like this table just for writing how
does it work I never done this this is
so hard I never doesn't look at that
welcome to Hokkaido katakana I gotta go
where are we we are in this tiny little
car going down this giant hill that we
went up for last night with two luggages
but we're going to visit some sup today
as all the day's surprise
god I'm good prank is that they got
7-elevens freaking everywhere they got
all the Japanese whiskey here in
Centauri
niek which autistic its aru this one is
amazing guys should I shave my beard
it's snowing oh my god another thing
that I love about Japan is that the
vending machines have hot drinks like
this is so high it's so nice
I stopped the recording
god dammit they're having such a laugh
over there this one is amazing
ma yeah you were right it is the Swedish
artists cars MELAS my granddad used to
be used to help sculpture for this
artist whoa
what is happening in here I have become
a robot come in Marcia come in and above
Oh
join us one of us were nervous
this place is beautiful
takes me back man Louie be hot spring
footbath going on over there oh that
feels amazing wow that's a big fall
that's a big ball Wow is he doing it oh
[Music]
hello everybody it's your favorite
vlogger Felix here Brett Hakone shrine
we're almost there it's freezing
where's the shrine where is it no one
knows maybe in three years we'll see the
shrine after PJ's done filming his
full-length feature documentary about
this lamp I think
soon we'll able to move on when he's
done with his lamp oh my god we're not
at the shrine yet guys that's okay
that's fine I want to walk upstairs we
found it
the shrine by the river we take the
really windy day to do this that's so
cool
this is unreal look at that
nice and warm
let's go upstairs
how's the light PJ it's a good lamb sigh
this is my shot that's my shot beautiful
it looks like such a homeless person
really like Hakone
reminds me of San Francisco no weird way
oh I run up the stairs successful day
fun times thank you we have a long bus
right now but it's kind of nice so
cool that's so dope much I'm
blogging I just came back from the onsen
so refreshing how do you like it yeah
it's so nice and now we've seen everyone
naked no not really
we were like hey don't look at my dick
man tomorrow it's the last day we're
traveling back to Tokyo I hope I can buy
a Gundam I hope we can go to the Gundam
place cuz I really want to build one
when I get back that's my goal for the
last thing of the trip good morning
we're leaving her Kona to go to Tokyo
and then tomorrow we're going home got a
well needed beard trim I'm so glad I
don't know why I didn't do it before we
are back in Tokyo that's gonna be me one
day
look at our so happy with that whiskey
it's happening it's happened in I'm so
excited as you can tell from my facial
expression which is about to blow oh my
god we're in America that's so crazy
I found it guys hurray crazy you want to
get inside you wanna operate oh my god
what if we steal it and fly it back just
Sweden so this is a real size one by
scale that's so cool
holy that's sick look at that these
are sick
what happened there these are the
perfect rain once holy Shay
there is so which one should I get
that was really clean and looking I like
it I'm so happy right now I'm like a
little kid this is so much how am I
gonna fit this in my luggage so
apparently that one and that one is the
same getting it oh it's lit so cool so I
got there this one that's the one I got
so I'm gonna build that one I'm so
excited I also got this japan-exclusive
I'm doing the whole literally outside so
cool I'm so happy with it I was so
excited when I found this guys this is
the end of all the Tokyo vlogs we had an
amazing time this is one of my favorite
Tokyo trips or Japan trips I loved it it
was great leave a like I'm gonna walk
back to Sweden now I don't live in
Sweden
someone helped me hello